تقف وفي قلبها وجع واسى على اطلال منزلها
وقد سوي بالارض نتيجه قصف طالة كتب لها
عمر جديد هي واسرتها جراء ما نزل بهم كل
شيء تحول الى انقاض دفنت تحتها طمانينتهم
التي كانوا يسكنون اليها تحت سقف منزل يضج
بالحياه في منطقه الكلاكله القبه التي تقع
جنوب غربي الخرطوم وتعد بعيده عن تخوم
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع لم تخفي هذه السيده حيرتها ان يطول
حيهم الشعبي المدني هذا قصف تضرر منه اكثر
من عشره منازل كلنا قاعدين فيها وامان
وسلام وما متوقعين اي حاجه نحن اصلا ما
عندنا حاجه مقضيه بالجيش ولا بدعم سريع
ولا اي شيء ما عندنا اي اتجاه سياسي عشان
نتجه اتجاههم نهائي احنا كلنا قاعدين في
امان الله تعالى يعني عندنا اي شيء عايشين
حياتنا عاديه جدا جدا وعندنا حاجه الذعر
التمسناه من سكان هذه المنطقه يقولون انهم
ليس لهم علاقه بما يجري وما يحصل ويتمنون
ان تتوقف هذه الحرب السريعا حتى يعيش
المواطنون باطمئنان وامان وسلام
هي تكافل سكان الحي معهم تتضافر جهودهم
لترميم ما امكن من البيوت لكن ترميم
مماسات من خسروا منزلهم برمته يبدو اكبر
وشق واضنى في ظل الاوضاع المضطربه هذه نحن
جوا البيت
وقمنا
على الغزيف والحاجات
الحته الباب قافل يلا باقي الحديد
والحاجات دي كلها دقت فينا
المصاب بالنسبه اليهم جلل
يتوافد الاهل والجيران لمؤازرتهم والتخفيف
عنهم فهذا البيت الاخر
تصدعت جدرانه وغدا سقفه متهالكا لا يقوى
على الصمود
يحاولون لملمه ما تبقى من امتعتهم للرحيل
والرحيل مر من بيت يحمل بين جنباته
ذكرياتهم عندها حاجه تعملها
في امانه الله قاعدين الضرب
من رب العالمين ربنا يعيننا بس
الدمار الذي طال هذه المنطقه السكنيه
البعيده عن محيط الاشتباكات خلف اسئله لدى
المتضررين منه وسكان الحي عن اسباب
استهداف منطقتهم التي يؤكدون خلوها من اي
شبهه تجعلهم في مرمى نيران الحرب محمد
الطيب الجزيره من منطقه الكلاكله الكبه
جنوب غربي الخرطوم